hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Madison
Beatty good job on the hair
anyway Madison's here today we're gonna
check out from all-time movies let's see
with the exact titles top ten hilarious
movie deaths thought we were doing
something light I know man it's about a
heavy anything - Ian - gotcha
done hey guys I'm Chris and B's on my
top 10 most hilariously over-the-top
dance these are the phones where the
attempt to be spectacular or dramatic
just went overboard into wrong hilarity
really the rock my name is Bob James's
father so let's begin number 10 Live and
Let Die
I mean of course James Bond would be on
this list James Bond had to be honestly
come on I mean now as far as Bond
villains go this is one of the funniest
but while living let die is an ironic
movie magus death is just so stupid and
the dummy is just so dumb that she just
stops being ironic
it just becomes kind of wild pathetic
really number 9 Rambo I'm so confused
you know the story
Rambo shoots a guy with an exploding
arrow
come on his face just look at me forever
- that that's the face I'm gonna make
and pensionable mention the [ __ ] seen
from commando I mean it doesn't really
count for this list but is it comment
it's just so over the top ha how could
I'm not include it number 8
enter the ninja Franco Nero that's right
the original Django played a not very
convincing ninja in this bizarre action
flick but the standard plot of corporate
bullies and vengeance is lifted into
timeless territory by this Dead Sea
Oh would you do that every time
at number 7 we have Broken Arrow my
strong who doesn't do subtle does he
ever know but even he when little bit
over-the-top with John Travolta's dead
Christian Slater beats the [ __ ] out of
him with Tiger sound effects and then he
actually [ __ ] nukes a guy he nukes
Lee right he's got even the missile rule
come on what is this a zoo
look welcome to the jungle you have a
six hour command oh the realest names
make is unlawful so bad but Nicolas
Cage's performance was amazing
specially in the extended edit it's just
Richard crazy let me get this they break
his legs and then they burn him alive
what is that what is that what is that
oh no not the Bears the Bears
nursing my eyes there's no but really
it's his overacting money or creepy CG
B's on him that makes that dead see it
was so special
delicious number five Asylum erotica mmm
Wow people by the title it's Charlie's
erotica moment there's a Klaus Kinski
now Italian giallo films don't do death
by heart but this one man this one is
just so ridiculous
oh just listen to that music
yeah I think is trying to be like watch
but hey I think Tom Cruise is a fan of
this phone number for undefeatable
to its credit this is suitable is a
nineties martial arts movie with the
female on the down side that's pretty
much the whole book like you personally
make sure that photographers get a shot
of this and what the reporters kept out
of here
not what that laboratory you got you got
still room for one of the harshest most
various bits ever
oh man that poor bad guy he gets the
[ __ ] beaten out of him
gets impaled on a spike then impaled
again on a meat hook from he's blind and
goodbye
he's hoisted away to power keep an eye
out
yeah Vigo number three mark deck yes
Steven Seagal does not go easy on
evildoers and hey this fella he gets it
gets all of it all of it oh man no one
was to be nailed by cigar number two
deadly fray
are you kidding
look at the boat look at you could see
the body you can even see the person's
elbow jetting out from under the
dressing gown but I mean that's really
that's true
I would've laughs believe it I'm kind of
disturbing himself apparently here the
director's cut without any violence or
gore I mean what but the producers made
in turn a weird teen romance into a high
school Terminator report well it's still
worth it for my screams and finally at
number one karate go now this is Turkish
form so obscure so bad that this is all
you will ever see it but it's definitely
all you do need to see oh my gosh no oh
no
not good side going to the frost I think
would happen you would end up at the
ball hugging this is huge on it are you
still alive
it is so bad that they spoofed it in
police what
yep so that's my pick of the most
unintentionally or maybe actually
intentionally what is nearly over the
top movie debts hey and if you enjoyed
this video please don't forget to Like
and subscribe and why don't you check
out the five most ridiculous James Bond
catchers this makes me very nervous to
do a bad project because they can get
very bad um yeah but some of them I kind
of don't agree with um I like when Rambo
blows up a guy with a that would never
made arrow it's like fun Hollywood shake
like that last one for example that last
one was the most ridiculous thing I've
seen in a long time or where she killed
him with a basketball why why can't it
well well it's because she's a cyborg
underneath so she's able to throw a
basketball strong enough that will cause
someone thanks you just and explode my
my mind just exploded yeah there are
other things I'll make you do that
there's a sex joke fitter somewhere I
really dug the answer the ninja death my
favorite part was when he got hit with
the star and then he was falling he's
like isn't epic why would you do that
man that was a great moment that was a
fact that last moment is what counts
why can you get out in last minute and
what's cool about this list is they're
choosing deaths that are supposed to be
like the epic death and to get the epic
death down that can be hard because it's
hard to give a really rewarding death I
do like the John Travolta one I think
that's pretty cool the odds of that
happening I don't know but I like
watching it he's a bad guy in them
seeing how that would happen if the odds
of a train and gasoline and that whole
thing were all aligned with a nuke the
stars were to align for John Travolta
that was cool he smiled before he got
hit by the nuke very epic moment great
choice yeah you know he always makes
solid choices in his roles Nicolas Cage
with the wicker man I love that like
bees would pour down that way
I know yeah you think when you're boring
be easy which is really a fly right like
I don't want to [ __ ] go in there yes
so I love how the bees
me by Nicolas head that's a silly
[ __ ] way to die I mean you break his
legs you're setting him on fire and then
what writer had that idea well it's a
remake it was remade by the same guy who
made the original I believe so
ok so that guy is smart he's a genius ok
smartest thing you could ever do gasps
Nicholas Cage liquid bees asylum erotica
totally says they get it it sounds like
my type of film I feel like I could make
a whole movie based off that title right
now why haven't you I don't know
asylum erotica yeah I make it just an
all-black cast that's good all black
cast you know why show I'm not racist
that's good all black dress yeah black
[ __ ] black dick sometimes I'm really in
the black porn but that's that's good
that's good you're diverse I'm diverse
mm-hmm
bbw big Blackman beautiful black woman
big black woman no beautiful blocking
you got shot in the head I know I think
he's like oh what's the movie called
what a headache gosh my head hurt the
karate girl death that was kind of
disturbing to me when he gets it put on
the Hulk about you think about being
your IV Donna Oh Karen
that was kind of just like some of these
dis I'm liking this kind then like with
the coat hangers I just think of
Monsters Inc because all the doors
oh hey conveyer belts and chick yeah
made monsters inc perverted sure there
must be hard to die you've never died
before
it must be hot enough how do you go
about dying um well as someone who has
killed many uh people I feel like I can
definitely channel watch watch okay how
do you want to kill me I'll show you
right now
acting classes watch I'll show you how
to die Shannon please don't kill me
then you kill me okay please don't kill
me nice
get your phone is it wait wait wait we
don't want Karim oh okay yeah please
don't kill me that's it okay was that
your way of killing you just hold the
knife up
that's a slice knife in front of you
would it be getting out this is it okay
doing this doesn't kill someone I'm here
to kill you for some reason I probably
you have to kill me Arnold
Schwarzenegger are you not getting the
point of this usual there you go why are
you so done well because you are doing
it right at first all right one more
time we're gonna get that ring though
we're gonna get this down try one more
time dropping mine just travel more time
Oh having a casual day and then oh my
god I got a major erection from that if
you guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects I got the
business to take care of right now and
you can check out Madison Beatty
wonderfully a talented actress featured
in the master Curious Case of Benjamin
Button reoccurring role on the Fosters
can't be seen outlaws and angels star in
Chad Michael Murray she has a Facebook
page are there a bikini photos on there
maybe are there no are there bikini
photos I'm avoiding your question die
again
thanks for watching guys - didn't except
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and periscope drop the
knife or the remote I scared the cat
well I'm like way more talented than you
I'm like why I don't know I don't know
why this is
/ I have something for you Ryan it was a
your birthday I'm a lame friend and yes
you're actually thank you okay that
makes me feel really good you're a lame
friend yeah and I was working on your
birthday so I didn't make it there but
it was just your birthday so ooh just
just for you the law I figured you'd
love the bow yeah I do love the bow yeah
it could be used for whatever you buy
certain erotic fixations yeah you could
put it up the bumhole asylum erotica
cookies whoo this looks great
mmm I need a pink totally your colors so
I like pink [ __ ] oh yeah you get some
like glitter it was your birthday you
deserve to feel like a fairy princess
maybe
see a great friend a great friend like
I'm in one cookie